trois cent cinquante mille portugais
vivent en ile de france ce sont les
travailleurs immigrés les plus nombreux
en majorité ils sont logés
individuellement
parfois on les trouve dans des cités de
transit comme à stains un reportage de
dominique rotival conserver son identité
culturelle est essentiel pour la
communauté portugaise à la cité de
transit de stains en seine-saint-denis
le mercredi matin est consacré à
l'apprentissage du portugais cette idée
existe depuis 1973 est destiné à
disparaître puisque les 96 familles qui
vivent doivent être relogés il existe
150 associations portugaises en ile de
france on se mobilise pour apprendre le
portugais mais aussi pour y faire
connaître le portugal centre sont toutes
orientées pour amener les gens de
l'extérieur sur la cité également les
jours n'a cité sur l'extérieur est-ce
que les portugais sont bien intégrés aux
mais je pense que c'est mieux qu'ils
restent portugais toute façon ce
paresseux sirkis un style plus de 60 des
portugais en ile-de-france sont des
ouvriers non qu'elle travaille pour 44%
d'entre dans le bâtiment et l'automobile
louise pantxo 41 ans est arrivé en
france en 1966 maçon de son métier il
travaille aujourd'hui dans une
entreprise de bois qui fabrique du
mobilier urbain
contrairement aux espagnols qui se sont
fixés dans le midi de la france les
portugais sont les plus nombreux autour
de paris le centre culturel portugais
avenue d'iéna existe depuis 1965
la vocation de cette institution privée
faire connaître la culture portugaise
surtout au niveau universitaire des
cours de langue ils sont dispensés et ce
en collaboration avec l'université de
vincennes
la bibliothèque contient quelques
quarante mille volumes la fondation est
aussi une maison d'édition notamment
pour les thèses
reste à savoir quel lien il existe
entre les deux cultures dont la france
est le pays que les portugais
généralement aime le plus
même depuis toujours à cause aussi du
fait qu ils se trouvent ou voiliers de
près d'un pays plus puissants l'espagne
qui a voulu naturellement l'étouffer et
naturellement on pensait à la france à
la culture française la france était
pour les portugais la partie la liberté
la fondation attribue aussi débourser
les étudiants en fin d'études et venance
spécialisé à paris